And that's the correct answer. All right. So let's
actually go through that exercise and derive how we
do that. because it's not so bad in two
dimensions and it generalizes to higher dimensions as well.
>> Okay.
>> So it turns out that we can use calculus to do this, I
am not going to step through the two-variable example for reasons that I am
embarrassed to say. But I am going to show you a different example. So
imagine that what we're trying to do is that we've got a bunch of data
points, and we're trying to find the best constant function, right? So the best
function that has the form, the value of the function for
any given X is always the same constant, C. So if our data looks like this, we
got a bunch of X's and a bunch of Y's,
then what we're going to do, we're going to say for
any given value of C, any given constant, we can have
an error. What's the error going to be? The error is
going to be the sum over all of the data points. Speaker 1: The square
difference between that constant we chose and what
the actual yi value is. So that's why.
>> Michael.
>> These differences here. Yes, Charles.
>> Can I ask you a question?
>> Sure.
>> Why are we doing sum of squares?
>> There is many different error functions and sometimes called
a, a relative concept called the loss function. There is
lots of difference once that could work, you can do
the absolute error, you can do the squared error, you can
do various kinds of squashed errors where you know. The
errors count different depending on how, how much deviation there is.
It turns out that this one is particularly well behaved
because of this reason that I'm explaining now that that because
this error function is smooth as a function of the constant
C, we can use calculus to actually find the minimum error
value. But there's lots of other things that could work and
they actually do find utility in various different machine learning settings.
>> Okay.
>> So just now using the chain rule, if
you want to find how do this error function
output change as a function of input c. We
can take the derivative of this sum you know,
bring the two over. Times this, times the derivative of the inside, which
is negative one in this case. And now this gives us a nice, smooth
function saying what the error is as a function of c. And if we
want to find the minimum, what do we want to do to this quantity?
>> Set it equal to zero, because that's what I remember from Calculus.
>> That's right. So in particular if the error you know, the error
function is a nice smooth thing the derivative is negative and then zero and
then positive. When it hits zero that's when the thing
has bottomed-out. Alright. So now we just need to solve
this, this equation for c. So we have one equation
and one unknown. Alright, so that gets us this. But,
this quantity, it's just the constant added to itself n
times. So it's n times c. We move that to
the other side. We get n times c. N is
the number of data points as you recall. Is the
sum of the yi's. We divide
two by n and what do we see? So what is it Charles?
>> The best constant is the average of all your y's.
>> Great, it's the mean. The mean comes back. Right, so
in the case of finding the best constant here, we just have
to average the y, the y's together and that catches thing that
minimizes the squared air. So squared air is this really nice thing
because it tends to bring things like mean back into the picture. It's really
very convenient. And, it generalizes to higher,
higher order of function tier, not higher
functions, but more variables like, like lines.
Sorry. Lines that have some, some non
constant slope. By doing the same kind
of process and things actually work really nicely.